the reason why I asked you to leave
space right here on my team now is
because the hitting his spoilers so we
will add it in later but it kind of
ruins the you may well be able to guess
it but um I'm not giving you any clues
or anything forget that like it's just
one gigantic close passage I'm not even
tell you how many words there are fine
let's have a go so the question is find
the sum of this okay now let's just
learn a few things before we even start
okay that's a sigma yeah okay now
there's two things firstly I have not
put s and that's usually what we've been
using as our notation for the sum of a
series can anyone see why I might not
say yes it does share the same pattern
I'm implying that it does share the same
poem but even when it shares its head
from the pan there is a problem what of
a second if you didn't see this right if
you just saw this that's you you know
with someone who'd never seen this
notation before what would you say that
means some of what some of what some of
the the first n terms right over
whatever serials therein lies the
problem this series and this is actually
part of the reason why this is
interesting to us this does not have n
terms you have to work out how many
terms there are but they sure aren't in
so there's the first problem I kind of
called this s of n because there aren't
in terms I'm putting that as well as
well because this not this one but the
Nexus here we're going to do is from the
program they call it that they're
relation because there are not in terms
now you might say well let's just call
it a saga of however many terms can you
score - right but we're also going to
try and avoid that because that has its
own special meaning okay so I'm gonna
call it s I stared over the course Sigma
so I need to go on something so there
you go now how might we go about this
this is is it let me ask this question
is this a finite series for an infinite
series fine do you think it's fine
yes who agrees right so it depends on
whatever you put in here if we're going
to assume which I probably should have
said this before that it is some kind of
integer right integers are finite so
therefore this thing we find that ok now
what I'm after is can we can be
evaluated now being that we don't know
what n is at the NT I'm not gonna get
like a number like 2004 of 1 okay
because this value is going to depend on
n right however I can get from you know
an indefinite number close to a definite
all of the numbers that belong in the
set of integers all of those numbers
have a value and it's not infinite it's
an actual number
so that's right so no matter how big we
make the number you know a million that
Beach renewing that's still fun if I
hadn't thought that would make any
issues there was even this would be
yeah see what you're getting so this 3
to the end right is our last turn so
suppose this was 2 to the power of 1
well last time would be to the power 3
if this is if my first thought was to
square my last term would be to have 6
right now if my first term is to the
power of 0 and the last term will be to
the power 0 so it will just be a series
with one terminal which is a bit weird
but that's what the series of hmm all
right
ok let's come back to this reasoning
let's rate a place of strategies to this
because we've looked at sorry the series
has an anything it's geometric how can
you tell it's got the power is it all
right that's right so I'm this the
dudesman here he is I multiplied by 2
you might want to get I can't call it
ratio get that language by the way you
know the way which side using it so
beaten is a core issue it's a GP okay
but we don't find the songs of GPS don't
we
what's the sum of a GP I'll give you a
tip it starts with the name
I think I think I heard it somewhere
that by the way I I saw the fun she's
this before but I didn't explain I
wonder if you've got away and rely on it
we said that this was not the only way
you ride it yeah I can also flip it
around it would be exactly the same
thing now is anyone worked out why might
we use water over the other or what
instead of Vietnam in what cases might
want this one case of racial riots it's
not gonna turn on oh yeah
now basically we want things to be
attacked as less as few negatives as
possible we know what double menus
that's confusing right so if R is a
fraction which we'll get to in a second
then you probably want to pick which one
this one right you know one - whatever
so you'll have a positive thing down
here as opposed to a fraction minus 1
will be negative and then you have a
negative up here double negative but why
bother but you can choose somewhat
lesser so for this which one would you
use that this series which one would you
use this one right because the ratio we
said was the really negative negative
numbers as the ratios of everything okay
no a negative number doesn't give you
decay it gives you Sabine theme it
actually could do an oscillation
positive negative positive negative
positive
okay before I actually put any more
whiteboard sorry my doubts a whiteboard
I'm not going to put numbers in Turkey
yet can anyone see there's a problem
with using this formula with this series
the first term is possible but it's an
expression
yes there's something more obvious
you've actually already noticed it but
writing this lines no one's called it
out as one pausing to think about it
it's not do you remember why did we say
I shouldn't right now because it's not
because there are not in terms right it
has a fire another trend is not in
what's invented by this all by - and now
this this year what does that signify
how many terms there are in the Sun
right so this this is wrong because an
has a meaning here right and then I
we've got a couple of different ways to
resolve this I think will be the easiest
way is to leave the formula as it is
because it is a formula so by the end of
this topic we will have memorize it so
it's good to just walking away right
well let's just rewrite this in a
slightly different way that we'll just
have less confusion the real problem is
that there's an N and there's another
end ok do factor also get there once
we'd rewrite this in a sort of more
hopeful way right so would you all agree
that between the first line and the
second line
I haven't changed anything it's the same
series right it's just got different
labels on it
yeah now the reason why I might write it
like this even though almost certainly
you will get it like this okay
is that I can now use this formula and
not get my ends confused okay because in
this question like actually the mass of
it's very simple just adding factorizing
all that but it's just getting the right
pieces together and not confusing all
right now I'm gonna ask you a question
in a second I'm deliberately not going
to give you a lot of time to answer
okay I'm gonna pose the question I'm
gonna give you five seconds I'm gonna
count out the five and then I want you
to shout out your answer out loud as
soon as I finish okay and the reason why
is because I want you I deliberately
want to only give you a short amount of
time to think about this and to see if
you could make a judgment on this okay
so here comes the question count to five
then out loud you ready no pressure
right okay
the question is now you don't have to
think about it what is and how many
terms are there in this series ready
clattering one two three four five now
okay so there are there were too many
answers and lots of people who weren't
sure what to say okay now okay I could
just tell you what the right answer is
okay I think you learn very much then if
I just said there it is oh it's can we
work out all right now if it is one how
can you know how did you go about doing
this so he's one he's one possible thing
15 would work better let's try something
a little okay so for instance let's
suppose it started at two okay so the
next one would be too cute next time
where am I going to end
at free end right which is actually yeah
1 2 3 4 5 terms right so automatically
automatically we know I'll get to that a
second automatically you would know this
is not going to be 2 enters because it's
an odd number right and you can try it
again I'm gonna [ __ ] with 3 I'm gonna go
7 terms and so on okay but Richard is
right like proof by example
yeah approved by the scientific method
which is repeated observations it
doesn't mean much in a math classroom
right is there any way we could go about
this which is a little more logical
facts rise out to let's give this a go I
think that's a that's a better way to go
about it because it's a little more it's
not just it works you know let's
actually try and put some analysis in
here so if I factorize okay what's gonna
be inside
okay I'm gonna put that guy over here I
need some space so that is 2 3 2 ends
are you a lady's head
okay now I'm trying to work out because
it's still the same number of terms
isn't it in here as there are everything
up there just for small okay so how many
terms are there here well you can see
from here to here right I start at 1 2 3
4 5 0 and I end up to M so there must be
two in terms there and then you've got
this to the 0 or this one and then yeah
here
okay so there's way my 2 n plus 1 comes
from okay
well really sorry I changed them
indicating that to avoid this problem
alright so we say 2 k plus 1 so now I
think I've got all the pieces to use
this guy what's the
the same okay good
what's the ratio we just sit with you k
plus one times one I should write it
actually certainly showed with okay so
let's just tidy up a little bit
index laws okay now what was the hard
thing about this method what was the
hardest part how to put all the steps I
think reason was find out of our terms
okay and I deliberately asked you to
give me an answer straight away because
I'm the exam conditions that's the kind
of thing you're forced to do right and
you get under pressure in a rush and it
is easy to get this wrong you know this
is UK plus one what if I gave you
different Susan it might be 2 K minus 1
or 3 k plus or whatever right you sort
of have to do this person up every time
n it's easy to get wrong and it's hard
to you know actually definitely verified
right so is there another way is there
another way to arrive at this air time
okay tell me what process did we go
through do you remember we did it the
end of the lesson and we did something
else there what do we do yeah we were
clever what what kind of clever ways I
see we're not going down a helpful
Avenue
we did some a dream manipulation with a
Series A Serbian right we multiplied it
by the ratio and that let us work with
it and that's where this fraction came
from okay you could say that was like
using first principles and then you
arrive at a formula and now we use the
formula right what turns out if we go
back to first principles like with this
original question
um even though usually we think first
principles is when you think of calculus
right first principles long shortcut
rules fast right and and less
error-prone okay but here I think this
is actually a better way to go so let's
start this is lankier
okay that's that's what the series is if
I were to use a first principles
approach trying to work out what singers
what was our exceptionally kind of thing
we did to get this formula
even how do we do that well why we were
doing something before we subtracted
anything didn't we multiply by something
what do we multiply by ratio right which
is two - okay so what am I gonna get on
the right time come on index laws that
times - yeah okay good okay right okay
now hold on a second now that I've got
that what did I do with this I should I
should subtract right subtract and on
factorize later so if I subtract the
original series right which is here I'm
gonna kill all of the terms in the
middle and I'll be left with one in the
end so one on the side one at the end
right
I'll have which ones give me the
leftover term
this is the term here which doesn't
appear in this series so that's like
it's left off right this is the term
that doesn't get caught
yes to Sigma minus Sigma is no tell me
how many toes me there in this series oh
wait I don't care I don't need to know
do i right
going back to first principles you don't
need to know how many terms there are
okay because this process isn't
predicated on how many times there are
whereas this formula is let's make sense
okay so what's the heading it's a very
main series by first principles this is
the video I was missing
okay now like I said as a comparison
with calculus right we why do we use
first principles in calculus answer only
because exam questions tell us to and
elsewhere we just don't waited because
it just takes too long right
but with series be different this
approach is actually far more elegant
right at least given this kind of
question all right now I'm gonna give
you another one and it's gonna require
some some thinking because it's even
though it's in the same kind of vein it
has a major difference to it which
complicates things sorry
he's the new series I'm going to
okay this is out of this um prevent by
the way I'd like you to find that this
something I'd like you to do it both
ways
I would like you to do it by the formula
just like we did here
and then do it by first principles okay
think carefully actually it doesn't
matter which order you do it in if you
don't do my first which was first that's
fine but the difference between the two
methods will I think become a little
more obvious when you do this particular
question okay so